basically it's a straight shooting sort
of conversation but I think that
sometimes we get distracted and we talk
about the bigger because between men and
women I think that the problem that men
and women have is the consequences of
the bad decisions that the one percent
of powerful men make on our behalf
because our problems are on a societal
level less than between woman and man
that is why there's a lot of competition
between men this trace for status that
they will never get men why is that the
fault of the one percent a man because
they're the ones that drive the machine
that runs this the Western it's always
been that way yeah and but then think
about them and the other top now the
corruption and everything that's going
on and this is why it feels very good to
sit next to somebody like you and just
say you know what I appreciate that you
say things that are really true you
expose a very toxic truth and a very
true truth as well that is out there but
the reality is on the trenches when you
go to the Grassroots people don't feel
the way that you feel it's not as simple
as what you say they are victims of this
system so my job here is really not to
try and make it about men and women is
to make you understand that actually we
need to start changing the narrative we
want to make it about men and women
because they're both messed up on either
side because then women look bad no
because it's about everybody together
women have their traumas men have their
traumas I'm not here to fight against
men and women that's small I understand
what you're saying I understand what
you're saying but the idea the idea the
idea that this one percent of men have
created this terrible Society yeah I
talk about that I talk about the Matrix
I talk about these things but it's
always been this way it's always been a
small Elite group of men who are in
charge of the world and unfortunately
now we're fighting battles in different
ways the the days of old a man proved
his worth by going to war basically
every man at any point in his life was
going to end up going to war and he came
back Victorious he came back with honor
he got himself a wife that's that's how
it worked right now men don't have to go
to war as much depending on where you
live in the world and it's slightly
different and we fight our Wars in other
ways and one of the true expressions of
testosterone and trying to really
express your ability and your combative
ability now in the in the modern world
is power and influence so in the olden
days you'd go to war you come back with
a ribbon nowadays you've got x amount of
followers you can move the world with
money I can bend reality with money
please understand if I walk into Jimmy
Choo they lock the door no broke he's
allowed in Tate's here and I buy
whatever the [ __ ] I want there's lines
outside because I'm there I bend the
world with money that's how I that's how
the wars are now won so you're talking
about high status males and then it's
always been that way now you have a
whole contingent of men who aren't dead
okay they didn't die in a ditch but
they're lonely as [ __ ] jerking off and
that's the reality of it and and women
don't give a [ __ ] about them and why
should you I'm not sitting here actually
[ __ ] on women in any way I think
women have a biological instinct to a
degree to try and find the best mate
they can because it gives them the
highest chance of survival and the harsh
realities of the world and if they look
at a man who's not capable they just
don't feel an attraction to him and
that's the bottom line of it and that's
why I actually most I'm largely
misunderstood I don't blame women for a
lot of the problems women are guilty of
certain things but I have a massive
amount of blame to place on men because
there's so many men who are genuinely
incompetent oh God was a chick I
wouldn't [ __ ] these losers either like
they're losers so it's hard
why don't you just find a regular nine
to five person it's gonna look after you
you can be his Queen why can't you just
do that why is everybody really rushing
I've got a man we don't go on social
media everyone know about social media
nine to five I gotta run property 32
years happiest Larry what is the problem
Oh the old-fashioned it can it works no
Auntie let me clarify when I meant one
percent is not the one percent of
Attraction I mean the actual people that
are in charge of the things that run the
world the way that what I'm trying to
say is that it's always been an umbrella
we've lived under but a different
functioned underneath it so why is it
going to affect me I'll explain why
because as Sir Mr Andrew King Tate said
thank you I will have this one after
this boys
it is I've been drinking lime juice as
well so as he very rightly said Society
has now evolved before men went to war
now men don't go to war so there's a lot
of sense of of no purpose that they need
to find and then on the women's side is
that the same way that a society evolved
and made men feel less purpose they have
now had to take on bigger purposes they
have to go to work like they didn't have
to do before they have to take care of
the family and work and all of these
things and they'll deal with the fact
that men are feeling a little bit like
out of you know the rubbish say what I'm
saying you get a nine to five person
right what is wrong with you going out
there find a regular nine to five person
right you can function underneath that
because I'm always saying the women say
oh we ain't got enough money we ain't
got enough money work with what the
man's got you're right work with what
the man's got you can make a manual
Alpha everybody wants to go and find
these top earning money find a nine to
five work regular save your money learn
to cook and not have takeouts and then
save your money as I did before then you
should direct this to the men that feel
upset because they're not like Angels
she's completely completely right I'll
give you I'll tell you this there's not
a girl on this panel or on the planet
today who couldn't walk outside and find
a man who's gonna be nice to her loyal
to her and make her his Queen women
don't want that
Chris Brown then Chris Brown
what the [ __ ] do you think is gonna
happen if I go to the car garage right
you have to make a decision what you
truly want in your life if you truly
want to just find a manager and look
after you and take care of you you're
going to be his Queen he's going to be
loyal you can find that all day but
you're gonna have to settle to a degree
where a lot of women perhaps are not
prepared to do that you see the you see
how women act they'd rather chase a
fraction of a real G's time than have a
hundred percent of the time of a [ __ ]
dude who they don't they don't respect
at that level and it's kind of going to
a car dealership you walk in there you
if you want reliability you can get a
Nissan but if you want to get a Ferrari
it comes with it comes with headaches
it's going to come with problems so when
girls say to me oh you know what Andrew
you know you should be loyal to men like
me don't have to be and you know that so
why the [ __ ] are you here trying to tell
me what to do because you know I don't
have to be loyal and all the girls I'm
[ __ ] don't have to be loyal so why
are you sitting there pretending you
expected me to be loyal when everyone
knew from ground up day one it was never
going to ever [ __ ] happen and you're
still here I think you're still texting
they're gonna be the one that changes
you oh no yeah
this is the female decision they sit
there and decide no I want this this
this this this cool then you're gonna
have to accept it ain't gonna be loyal
to you he's barely gonna reply to you
that's the game they like me and cheated
I swear to God this show has made me
believe I think women like to be cheated
on I don't I swear to God no because all
you'll ever talk about is your exes that
cheated on you that's all you'll ever
talk about and it's like it's always
talks about that the regular women are
running the women oh good thing I'm
irregular and extraordinaire but do you
not think it's because we're not holding
men accountable so when I'm mad because
he's a top J cheats on a woman it's like
well what do you expect when you should
actually turn around
is cheating morally correct yes it
depends yes
how can you say that are you okay with
your woman cheating on you then
absolutely not that's all right no
because oh that's a wrap with she cheats
on you but you can cheat on her there
has not been in the history of humanity
across any culture any book any story
any Fable there has never been across
the history of humanity any respect put
on the name of a promiscuous female ever
ever you name the biggest conquerors
that you can possibly name from history
Genghis Khan Alexander the Great all of
them they all had 100 wives bunch of
children Big G conquered the world
normal that is normal evolutionary
biology that's how men are designed to
be there's never been a single female
who's been celebrated for a promiscui
ever in history it's always been frowned
upon and disgusting so yes we are
completely and utterly different yes
it's different if a woman cheats on a
man and if a man is at a complete top
level of his life and ticks every single
box and if he decides to be loyal which
some do and I can be loyal and I have
been loyal but there's also times in my
life where I think [ __ ] okay I don't
want to be and get a new girlfriend
every single day of the week I can do
that and I can decide to do that if a
woman decides to do the same purely
because her value is high enough to
attract so many males because she's
beautiful for example it is completely
different and I'm gonna explain to you
why it's completely different so buckle
up it's different it's different it's
different well I'll tell you why it is
impossible for a female to be
promiscuous on a long enough period of
time without devaluing herself because
she is [ __ ] people she shouldn't be
[ __ ] there's no way she is sleeping
with endless men and all of them are
either high value men or treating her
the way she should be treated if you
find a woman who slept with 50 100 dudes
she's either [ __ ] dudes which are at
her level or haven't worked hard enough
to try and get the [ __ ] juice is too
drunk to realize he's a loser who plays
video games or she's [ __ ] a top G who
barely texts her back so either way
she's [ __ ] dude she shouldn't be
[ __ ] or a guy who's at the level who
doesn't give her the right amount of
attention for a woman to find a guy
who's truly on a level who truly treats
her the way she should be treated that's
once every couple years if that you
ain't just gonna go out there [ __ ] a
new dude every week and say yeah he's
worth [ __ ] yeah he treats me good
enough to get my [ __ ] and you know
what's funny about the universe it's
actually beautiful about the universe
because it's equal and opposite forces
when you devalue yourself it's kind of
like men can smell it on you they can
just look at a [ __ ] and go oh and
that's the way it works so you have to
be very careful as a female and sit and
go does this man truly deserve to [ __ ]
me if you think about it the answer 99
of the time especially if you're
promiscuous is no so when a woman is
sleeping around with all these men she's
devaluating herself she's devaluing
herself and the world knows God knows
the universe knows when a man does it he
doesn't devalue himself at all that's
just the way it works can I ask you a
question wait wait wait answer one
second son may I ask you a question what
would you say if a woman now is married
to two men
no I'll tell you why let's talk about
this what is the difference between a
man let's say me I have four wives right
what's the difference between a man
having four wives and a woman having
four men you can impregnate the four
wives at the same time you're gonna
pregnant the four wives at the same time
and we know who the parents are right so
let's say you had four pregnancies you'd
know who the mother is because she's
carrying the baby and you know who the
dad is top G if you had a woman with
four men and she gets pregnant who's
supposed to parents what about if I'm
asking okay I ask what if they're
different races
you don't know the question you don't
know now modern science can come along
and maybe fix that for you but that
doesn't mean it's not wrong in the eyes
of God the idea of having a family the
idea of a child being born one of the
baselines for a new life to come onto
this planet is for at least to
understand who the two people who made
it are at least if you have a woman
[ __ ] four Dudes you don't even know
who's who who are pregnant so may I just
disgusted wait wait have you seen the
twins that had two different dads oh
yeah I saw that may I just say something
then so if that is the case yeah if the
one thing that you meant to Hobbies you
at least you know who the two people
that put that child on Earth are then
that's why promiscuity for men is also a
problem because they get women pregnant
sometimes they don't even know they have
children that's around no no it's
completely different it's different
because you have to understand I'm
talking about humans you look at humans
from a societal perspective but Society
has changed right so let's say two 300
years ago if a woman got pregnant she
needed a man to survive if that man
didn't take care of her during pregnancy
she was going to die she couldn't work a
job she couldn't hunt couldn't fish
whatever right a woman literally needed
that man for survival so if if you were
to come to me and say I'm pregnant but
you've been [ __ ] by four different
dudes I'm like who says it's mine why am
I looking after you none of them want to
look after her she will literally perish
this is why in most of the world today
still today Virginia is so coveted and
throughout all of history it's been so
coveted because that's the only way to
ensure paternity she's a virgin I know
that's my baby she ain't a virgin prove
it's mine outside of this modern science
[ __ ] shaitan the devil we have here
in the West in most of the world today
without virginity or at least a low body
count or at least uh anti-promiscuity
you can't tell that that's your baby so
it's a completely different thing you're
looking at the idea of a man a woman
being pregnant and coming to a group of
men and saying one of you has to take
care of me and put up with me when I'm
fat and Moody and annoying and I need my
bills paid and all the men are gonna sit
there and go no [ __ ] no prove it's mine
you can't prove it bounce where it's
different if I get four women pregnant
we know that we know the deal okay so
let me ask you a question as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible